In this video, you're
going to see the future.
Not everyone is trying
to win a popularity contest.
Case in point, this guy.
I don't think that popularity
is something he's interested in.
He's interested in effectiveness.
I've gotta give it up.
His air time, so to speak, is only a tool
to achieve what his
greatest aspiration is,
which is to have a positive
impact on the world.
You should look at, you
know, what was your goal,
how are you trying to uplift nutrition
and survival and literacy.
He is influential, A,
because of his vast fortune
and the way he made it,
by creating a new segment
of the computer market.
But also, that he's since then,
chosen to deploy the money he's made
to try to completely alter
the landscape of world health.
This year his net worth reached
as high as $120 billion.
These two have donated more money
to charitable causes than anyone ever.
He's a multidimensional individual.
He has great depth in
so many different areas,
I guess you'd call him a polymath.
William Henry Gates the third
was born in Seattle Washington in 1955.
He was a terrible child,
Bill senior gave a whole interview
to the Wall Street Journal
about just how difficult he was,
how much trouble he gave his mother.
You know, yelling, screaming,
tantrums, things like that.
At the ripe age of 13,
the problem child wrote
his first software program.
A Tic Tac Toe game on the
Teletype Model 33ASR teleprinter.
Eight years later, he
dropped out of Harvard
to start a computer software company
with his best friend Paul
Allen, called Microsoft.
In co-founding Microsoft, what Bill Gates
and Paul Allen did was,
essentially create the personal
computer software market.
That's since then been worth
hundreds of billions of dollars.
This is Jeff Raikes,
he's known Bill for quite some time now.
I was at Microsoft from 1981 to 2008
and Bill was completely
committed to the vision
that we could help put
a computer on every desk
and in every home, running great software.
And that's the impact
that he wanted to have
and he was completely focused in on that.
Now, such determination
does require a strong
personality, and it's safe to say
that his subordinates
could probably relate
to his parents at that point.
Well, he was a very tough
manager, people were,
had these sort of terrifying
Bill Gates reviews
of their products and features.
And if he didn't like what
you said he would, you know,
he was known for
responding with the words.
Well that's the stupidest
thing I've ever heard.
But the good news is, you
won't hold the record for long.
Seattle's Bill Gates, with $4.2 billion,
is the second richest
person in the country.
What is this?
It's Microsoft Excel, now hold still,
I'm about to perform a miracle.
My spreadsheet doesn't do that.
Microsoft became such a juggernaut
that the following decade they were sued
for being a monopoly.
If you look at that
point in the year 2000,
and Microsoft is in
serious anti-trust trouble
and the view of Bill at
that time was terrible.
And people viewed him
as a sharp elbowed,
monopolist essentially.
Not that he cared
about what the world thought of him,
but it was around this
time that Bill decided
to start listening to his parents.
I do remember in the
early days of Microsoft,
his mother pressing young
Bill to get involved
with the united way and philanthropy
and Bill's response was you
know, Mom, I'm you know,
I'm trying to build this company,
I don't really have time for that.
And I think over time, what he learned is,
in the same way that he could leverage
his intellectual energy
on behalf of Microsoft,
he could do it on behalf of philanthropy.
While in the midst of
this anti-trust suit,
Bill and his wife Melinda donated
$16 billion worth of stock
to charity in 1999.
The following year he
poured $5.1 billion in cash
to create the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation.
At this point I think people, many people,
much more closely
associate him with programs
that have saved lives and you know,
increased immunizations
in the developing world.
That's much more the popular
view of Bill at this point,
that sort of philanthropist
and not the monopolist so to speak.
So you can avoid lots of diseases
if you've been properly vaccinated.
Today, the Foundation
is the world's largest charity.
It's fingerprint is on almost
every global health initiative
of the last 20 years.
And has spent over $40
billion on global development
and public health programs.
Yes, they deploy financial resources
but they also use their voice.
The networks of influence
and support that they have.
So in many ways, it represents
one of the key concepts
that we learned on software,
it's about leverage.
What Bill wants, what Melinda
wants, with the Foundation
is to be able to make
those financial investments
and leverage them to have
the greatest possible impact.
By using this approach to philanthropy,
the Foundation provided seed
money to The Global Fund
to fight aids, tuberculosis and malaria.
Their implementation of immunizations
in the developing world has
contributed to a dramatic drop
in the overall child
mortality rate since 1990.
Bill also made it his personal mission
to eradicate polio from the planet,
something he has come
very close to achieving.
Then of course there's Bill's
noblest pursuit of all.
I wanna talk to you today about toilets.
Many people would say, well
why get involved in toilets
and how does that matter.
But that, you know, actually
kinda diving into that
explains a bit about how
Bill thinks about things.
If you want to reduce the disease burden,
you're gonna have to improve sanitation.
If you're gonna improve sanitation,
you're gonna have to invent
a new way to go about it,
one that doesn't require all
of the water that we use today.
So it's a great example of how he thinks
in terms of the broader system
and looks for technological innovations
that can really make a difference.
This push to improve sanitation worldwide
has led to the invention
of the Omniprocessor,
a low cost human waste treatment plant
with a beta version currently
in use in Dakar, Senegal.
I am very impressed
with this solution we're seeing here.
And it generates electricity,
it generates clean water.
In the area of climate change,
Gates has embraced the
often unpopular solution
of nuclear energy as an
alternative to fossil fuels.
The energy has to come from somewhere.
You're giving up all coal,
all natural gas, all oil.
It is a good example of both, in the fact
that he isn't concerned about
public opinion or popularity,
but grounded in what he believes
to be the data and the facts.
A Gates company called Terrapower
was very close to building the
world's first nuclear reactor
fueled by actual nuclear waste, in China.
But progress was stopped in its tracks
when Trump launched a trade
war against China in 2018.
No sooner was this vision put on hold,
than did Gates have a more urgent calling.
This is going to be era defining.
And no one was in a better place
to say, I told you so.
The most urgent invention
in the world right now
is a vaccine that prevents
you from getting COVID-19.
The fact that he has such depth
across so many areas makes him unique
at being able to take
on the current pandemic.
He has now spent 20 years
learning about funding programs,
talking to leading researchers
on things like viruses,
things like vaccines.
Some of the programs in the Seattle area,
including the Seattle flu study
that caught some of the
first COVID cases here,
are things that have been
funded out of the Foundation.
So far, Gates has chipped in
a total of $300 million and counting
in the fight against coronavirus.
They're focused on detection, isolation
and treatment of the virus
and finding a vaccine.
This chapter in Bill's life
has yet to be written,
and could have the highest
stakes he's had to face yet.
His intellectual intensity
sometimes carries over
to big expectations.
But at the end of the day,
the person he's toughest on, is himself.
If he doesn't figure out something
that he thinks he should have figured out,
he'll be disappointed in himself.
It drives him, it motivates him,
it gives him a sense of urgency
to really make a difference.
And I think that's one of
his greatest attributes.